Each year at commencement,
our university recognizes an
exceptional group of
individuals with
honorary degrees. These degrees
are the most significant
distinction conferred by the
Yale Corporation,
the university's board
of trustees, to signal
pioneering achievement in a
field or conspicuous and
exemplary contribution to
the common good.
Though we cannot adorn this
year's honorary degree
recipients in their
academic hoods
or applaud their
accomplishments
as they stand on the
commencement stage, we gather
virtually to recognize their
achievements and we express our
gratitude for the ways they
have expanded the frontiers of
knowledge and enriched our
world through science, art,
innovation and service.
Today, we honor nine
individuals who serve as
examples to our graduates and
members of the Yale community.
They encourage us to aspire to
excellence and to value those
elements of human character
that they embody.
Creativity, curiosity,
discipline, integrity,
and a passion
for public service.
Collectively, they represent
Yale's highest aspirations as a
university dedicated to
"light and truth."
and their association with the
Class of 2021
honors the students
who graduate today.
Now, it is my distinct pleasure
to announce the
2021 honorary degree recipients
and to confer their degrees.
For the degree of
Doctor of Fine Arts,
Ava DuVernay, filmmaker
Creator and critic, you portray
the richness and variety of
human experience
from all angles.
By elevating others, you bring
new stories into focus
and amplify voices we
need to hear.
Hollywood maverick,
for challenging us to
reckon with our past and our
present and for working to
change both an
industry and society.
Yale is pleased to
confer on you
this Doctor of Fine Arts
degree.
For the degree of
Doctor of Social Science,
Daniel Todd Gilbert,
social psychologist.
Fearless investigator,
generous teacher, you connect
the laboratory to our lives,
applying the fruits of research
to our search for happiness.
With humor and understanding,
you explore memory,
imagination and emotion,
helping us look more clearly to
the future. For stumbling on
answers to life's great
questions and sharing them
widely, Yale is happy to award
you the degree of
Doctor of Social Science.
For the degree of
Doctor of Laws,
Dolores C. Huerta,
community organizer.
From the fields to the
statehouse
you have united people
in pursuit of justice.
Your skills as an organizer are
matched by the strength of
your convictions: that there is
dignity in labor, that rights
are worth fighting for,
and that people power is the
strongest force on earth.
Courageous advocate for showing
us that, yes, we can
change the world.
We are honored to present you
with this
Doctor of Laws degree.
For the degree
of Doctor of Humanities,
Robert Farris Thompson,
art historian.
Scholar of improvisation,
connoisseur of cool,
your work
celebrates the sights,
sounds, and towering
achievements of
the Black Atlantic. With
joyful curiosity, you explore
the flash of
the spirit while mentoring
generations of students.
Professor of mambo,
Beloved "T":
for contributing so much to the
rhythm of our lives,
Yale is privilege to present
you, one of our own, with your
fourth Yale degree,
Doctor of Humanities.
For the degree of
Doctor of Medical Sciences,
Donald R. Hopkins,
physician and epidemiologist.
Courageous and brilliant,
warrior against disease,
you have slain the
"fiery serpent"
and subdued
"the greatest killer".
From Atlanta to Sierra Leone,
and bedsides
around the globe,
you purged ancient plagues and
delivered healing to millions.
In appreciation of
your dogged determination
and life-saving compassion,
We humbly bestow on you
the degree of
Doctor of Medical Sciences.
For the degree of
Doctor of Humane Letters,
Stephen Colbert,
writer and comedian,
Modern day jester, your satires
and set-ups have shaped our
culture and our politics.
Whether playing a character,
playing it straight, or having
it both ways, you take us
beyond truthiness and turn our
attention to urgent issues.
Award winning-wit, for using
your creativity, talent, and
craft to engage us
in the work of democracy,
we are delighted to
confer on you this
Doctor of Humane Letters degree.
For the degree of
Doctor of Letters,
Judy Blume, author.
Gifted storyteller, nothing is
off limits and no taboo is too
great for your uncensored
and honest voice.
Treasured by readers young and
old, you pushed past
shame and convention to help us
understand the world and our
place in it. For championing the
freedom to imagine,
while encouraging us
to love ourselves,
Yale is forever proud to
award you this
Doctor of Letters degree.
For the degree of
Doctor of Science,
Nergis Mavalvala,
astrophysicist.
Intrepid explorer,
inspiring role model, your work
shifts paradigms and opens new
windows onto the universe.
With precision and originality,
you have devised instruments
that will detect ripples in the
vast expanse of space
and time, raising ever larger
questions about the enigmas of
the cosmos.
In recognition of
your stellar discoveries,
we gratefully present you
with the degree of
Doctor of Science.
For the degree of
Doctor of Divinity,
Rabbi Lord Jonathan Sacks,
religious leader.
Championing
dialogue over division
Rabbi Lord Jonathan Sacks
called us to work together to
fulfill our responsibilities
and heal the world.
A respected scholar,
esteemed teacher of Torah,
and a light unto the nations, he
dedicated his life to
serving others, showing us what
it means to put "we" before "I."
In recognition of his wise and
steadfast moral leadership,
Yale is honored to confer this
Doctor of Divinity degree
posthumously on
Rabbi Lord Jonathan Sacks.
Zecher tzadik livracha.
On behalf of the Yale community,
I send my most heartfelt
congratulations to all of you.
The entire university joins me
in applauding your
accomplishments,
and welcome to the
Class of 2021!